[Music]
[Applause]
alright here's the deal this is a
segment where viewers try to find
mistakes on our show why do they do that
because we encourage them to yes we dare
them right Ryan find us making a mistake
so far
millions of challengers not one winner
we've never made a mistake never all
right well tonight a fan in Israel says
he thinks he caught a mistake his name
is guy Kesler he says it happened when
he turned when we turned Andy's lectern
into a dreidel for Hanukkah last month
hey they're gonna an a there and II am
pretty sure just got an error it was
when you called Andy to the stage with
the dreidel customer
[Applause]
as an Israeli Jewish I know the right
orders of the matters on the dreidel let
me show you what I mean the right order
is like this known then email then hey
then Sheehan which means the great
miracle happened there the wrong way
Yahweh was known shame diem of hey which
means the great happened miracle there
which doesn't make sense
still it's the thought that counts but I
think I caught it who you gonna trust on
this and Israeli or Conan O'Brien's
right no I know I think he's right and
what he's saying is that I confuse the
order of the words in our translation
well I'm sorry guy but you are
absolutely wrong
I did have those Hebrew letters ordered
correctly that's because the original
Hebrew phrase really does translate as a
great happened miracle there sounds
weird but that's what it is don't
believe me take a look at this very rare
1500 year old footage oh that was
unearthed quiet from Israel from Earth
from the lake bed of the Dead Sea
Master why the letters of the dreidel in
this order mm-hmm
shin Tim oh hey the letters are a great
happened miracle their master mighdal
all cheese talk like you starved by
childhood experience I was circumcision
gone wrong yes but spin kendama spin
[Applause]
[Music]
that takes care of that
done and done done and done hmm so the
challenge still stands if you think
you've sported an air up on our show
I'm mayor Quimby reported at team
koco.com slash ha ha I found an error we
will sort it out right here on the air
let's see if you've got what it takes to
make chump meat out of the maestro we'll
be right back